pour continuer cette fuite j'accueille à
présent pascal duo bonjour vous êtes
conseillère pédagogique en eps et jérôme
hong orieux goriot vous êtes conseiller
pédagogique aussi en eps on va évoquer
ces journées de rencontres
départementales que vous préparez pour
les 20 27 juin et 2 juillet également
plus de 700 élèves qui vont se
rencontrer sur trois sites des yvelines
guyancourt son plaisir également autour
du golf et de l'escrim ces journées
c'est l'aboutissement d'un long travail
parce qu'à l'école en eps ont fait pas
que du football où peu de l'athlétisme
maintenant on fait aussi du golfe
d'escrimé depuis quand un département
alors bas depuis très longtemps je crois
que c'est une des grandes finalités de
les questions physiques et sportives
c'est de permettre l'accès les élèves un
patrimoine culturel donc de sortir des
activités qu'on connaît tous et d'aller
vers les éditeurs plus innovantes sont
des activités qui viennent en complément
des activités un peu plus traditionnel
que l'on voit à l'école le golf ça fait
bien une dizaine d'années que s'est
développé sur le département
on a une convention qui a été renouvelé
en 2009
et puis les scream c'est depuis 2008
qu'on a développé un partenariat avec la
ligue des yvelines des scream savait
rien toutes les écoles ont accès à des
équipements pour favoriser la pratique
du golf et alors ça dépend ça se dit sûr
sous différentes formes en fait donc on
fait des propositions aux écoles c'est
sur le sur la base du volontariat bien
sûr ce ne sont que les écoles qui
souhaitent s'inscrire dans ces projets
qui y participent
on leur met du matériel à disposition
par exemple sur le golf on leur permet
d'accéder à des golfs partenaires sur
une ou deux séances
et puis il ya des formations en place
d'un sûr pour les enseignants et puis se
mener à bien ces modules d'apprentissage
et puisque la clé là aussi ce sont les
enseignants qui doivent être
complètement ce qui concerne l escrime
il ya des formations qui sont proposées
aux enseignants pour ensuite pouvoir
conduire seuls avec leurs élèves des
modules de formation et les rencontres
sportives sont un peu l'aboutissement de
ces modules de formation
un conte sportif qui se déroule le 20 27
juin 3 juillet c'est le bilan est à 2
juillet bilan vous allez faire un petit
peu de ces opérations sur ces trois
jours ça va se dérouler comment ce sont
les élèves de toutes les classes qui ont
participé qui est ce qu'ils échangent
qui s'affrontent alors pour le golf je
parlais polo gold donc là le 20 juin
prochain sur le golf national de
guyancourt le 2 juillet ce sera à moi
sont donc on a 75 classes qui sont
inscrits dans une dispositif
départemental dont je vous parlais tout
à l'heure et ses classes on leur a
proposé d'anticiper une rencontre
départementale donc oui on en a retenu
14 parce qu'on peut pas non plus
accueillir toutes les classes donc on a
essayé de que l'ensemble du département
soit représentée sur ces routes
voilà donc c'est sur la base du
volontariat ils vont se rencontrer sur
un parcours donc au golf national sur le
parcours de loiselet et donc voilà il
faut un parcours presque professionnel
tout à fait tout à fait
nos mondes très bons résultats ils sont
tout à fait performant comme ils ont
déjà eu accès sur une séance sont déjà
entraînés à proximité de l'école avec
leurs danses et nous ils ont eu accès
sur une séance à 1 golfs partenaires
dont qu'ils connaissent et très bons
résultats à l'école face à ses ennemis à
tout à fait un moment et puis si une
activité nouvelle qui change un peu
justement des autres activités qu'ils
ont l'habitude de pratiquer ils sont
souvent impressionnés quand il arrive
sourit golf aussi parce que c'est vrai
qu'il ya une ambiance particulière il ya
beaucoup de respect des lieux des autres
respect de l'étiquette et c'est donc ils
sont très responsables du sport
éducation citoyenne qui est essentielle
sur le golf est très importante et une
égale une éducation la sécurité aussi
puisqu'il ya quand même un danger qui
vient du bois l'outil faut qu'ils soient
très respectueux des règles que l'on met
en place on va continuer à cet échange
on va parler c'est de l'escrim plus
particulièrement cette fois-ci partie de
dés des activités qui sont qui sont
proposés juste un micro trottoir une
petite pause avec cette question faut-il
développer l'enseignement du golfe à
l'école voici vos réponses
pourquoi pas surtout que le golf n'est
pas loin de chez nous en plus donc il
n'y a pas de problème pourquoi pas je
prends la marche
c'est bien après intellectuellement
peut-être mais je pense que ça reste
quand même un sport que tout le monde ne
pratiquent pas c'est aussi donner la
chance à des enfants qui ne seront
peut-être pas ça plus tard de le faire
oui parce que moi j'en fais là oui c'est
un sport qui demande quand même
une dextérité de concentration trouvé ça
va être intéressant et tout à fait ma
foi toute expérience est bonne à tout
âge donc oui pourquoi pas harry mais
certainement pédagogiquement oui
j'imagine que
c'est pas mieux qu'un autre sport mais
en tout cas c'est très intéressant plus
original que le football ou autre chose
oui c'est un bon sport moi je pense que
ça peut être une bonne activité pour les
enfants oui pourquoi pas les saint
quentinois on l'entendait y sont plutôt
favorables on entend aussi que c'est un
sport peut-être encore d'élite ça va
permettre aussi de casser cette image là
justement voilà par la pratique le
scolaire on arrive à démocratiser un
petit peu ce sport est un des enfants à
pratiquer lors il ya aussi des bourses
qui sont donnés à quelques élèves qui
suite à cette découverte par le biais
d'une scolaire qui auraient envie de
pratiquer et de continuer donc le comité
départemental de golf offre des bourses
à quelques élèves pour leur permettre
justement de ne pas avoir ce barrage de
l'argent est toujours accéder ça sera
peut-être formation plus complet future
star du golf il ya forcément un enjeu
puisque en 2018 il y aura la ryder cup
ce sera à saint quentin en yvelines
d'ailleurs sur le golf national le rider
capon je vous rappelle ce sont les
meilleurs européens face aux meilleurs
américains qui s'affronteront on espère
qu'il y aura bien évidemment des
français dans la sélection ça on va
attendre un petit peu encore pour le
savoir il est dans le cadre de cette
série de recueils justement il ya un
partenariat les choses vont un
partenariat qui se met en place avec la
communauté d'agglomération de saint
quentin et puis également pas avec la
fédération française de golf qui est des
partenaires de l'alstom et puis le
comité départemental de golf donc pour
sensibiliser le plus possible des élèves
à cet événement mondial
et puis les a menés justement à
s'intéresser à ces pratiques
car si vous n'êtes pas et les vins que
vous voulez vous sensibiliser aussi au
golf et je vais juste vous faire une
petite parenthèse puisque la communauté
d'agglomération proposera plusieurs
dizaines d'animations au cours des
prochains mois au cours même des
prochaines années la première de ses
opérations ce sera vendredi 28 juin à
partir de 19 heures devant la
médiathèque françois truffaut c'est à
montigny le bretonneux lra parcours de
street golf dans les rues de saint
quentin encadré par un collectif le 19e
trou et puis le lendemain durant le week
end samedi et le dimanche il y aura la
possibilité toujours au même endroit
devant cette médiathèque à montigny de
faire un practice sur l'eau ou encore un
espace street golf en espace parcours
une exposition autour du golf nous
aurons à l'occasion bien sûr d'en
reparler on va s'intéresser à l'essai
juste ajouté il ya déjà 1000 élèves
aussi con participer à des journées
sensibilisation golf dès cette année
toutes les tous les élèves
la circonscription de guyancourt donc
c'est à dire les villes de manille de
voisins-le-bretonneux nuls en cours qui
ont sorti une journée sensibilisation
voilà donc mille élèves qui ont déjà
participé cette année ces journées
sensibiliser rendra également sur ces
journées qui sont dédiés cette fois-ci
peut-être plus aux familles forcément qu
aux élèves il y aussi les scream qui est
développé dans le cadre de ce programme
puisque ces différentes journées de
bilan que vous allez organiser vont
concerner aussi les scream pas
uniquement le golf même chose comment se
passe au quotidien la pratique de
l'escrimé dans ces classes
quelles classes sont concernées alors
comme comme pour toutes les rencontres
départementales donc elle mise à
disposition du matériel qui est proposé
aux classes donc on est arrivé jusqu'à
90 classes sur certaines et des
scolaires concernés directement par
l'activité des screen par un prêt de
matériel mais aussi par des formations
en direction des enseignants
alors bien entendu comme pour les
rencontres golfique on ne peut pas
réunir les 90 places donc il ya une
sélection qui est opérée qui prend
compte bien sur les éléments
géographiques pour avoir une
représentativité du département sachant
que les classes qui sont concernés coup
à peu près tout départements nord sud
est et ouest
donc là aussi c'est un succès c'est
pratique de découverte de l'escrimé par
rapport aux qualités aussi que ça permet
d'enseigner aux élèves ont parlé de
l'étiquette par exemple tout à l'heure
l'importance de l'éthique et au golf sa
place et là on est dans un affrontement
duels donc la nécessité s'il ya ou
d'avoir des règles est d'avoir des codes
qui sont très importants allaient ce
crime est aussi une coordination motrice
1,6 par rapport aux déplacements et aux
attaques et aux fantômes on appelle en
escrime
donc ça c'est très important et ça nous
permet aussi en fin d'année donc le 27
juin donc dans l'enceinte dû palais des
sports de plaisir de réunir on se casse
qui vont pouvoir s'affronter à travers
des activités physiques mais qui vont
pouvoir aussi avoir accès à une
conférence historique aussi accès à des
ateliers escrime artistique ou là on est
plus dans la démarche de création le
sport à l'école c'est le golf c'est
l'escrimé également est-ce que vous
travaillez sur le développement d'autres
projets d'autres disciplines quels sont
les sports qu'ils sont
mise en avant dans les écoles alors oui
on travaille sur différents projets bon
on a mis en place des activités
nautiques sur le département des
yvelines qui sont en partenariat son
appât pour évoquer mes sacs toutes ces
actions se déroulent dans le cadre d'un
partenariat important sinon on ne
pourrait pas mettre tout ça en place et
donc il ya cinquante trois classes c'est
elle qui ont pu naviguer sur les
différents plans d'eau du département
est le vôtre 4 mai dernier donc on a pu
réunir onze classes autour des activités
nautiques mais aussi vélique puisque
nous avions des ateliers le char à voile
quelque chose qui est relativement
nouveau puis ça fait deux ans qu'on a
mis ça en place auprès de nos classes
qu'il ya beaucoup de développement de ce
sport et il y aussi la santé inquiète et
qui est très développée sur notre
département en partenariat réalisé
zilina tennis giga que ce soit le tennis
que soit la future mariée comités
départementaux ou les ligues et dans les
autres départements de france on
retrouve le même genre de partenariat ou
est ce que dans les yvelines où mais
plutôt à la pointe sur ce genre
d'initiative où on est à la pointe je
pense c'est sur l'aspect on a une
commission une commission partenariat
c'est dire que décision tant de
rencontres sont prises ensemble un
partenariat entre l'éducation nationale
les ligues les comités le conseil
général avec des échanges
on n'a pas tous nécessairement les mêmes
finalités on arrive à attendre même
d'objectifs pourra développer ça ça ne
s'est pas le cas dans tous les
départements
donc l'effet bon être élève dans le
département des yvelines voilà pratiquer
ce sport à l'école merci à tous les deux
jours donne les dates ans pour ceux qui
s'étonneraient voir autant d'enfants
font sur les terrains de golf et même
dans les gymnases des scream dans les
prochains jours 20 27 juin et puis 2
juillet un rencontre pour valoriser ce
travail qui est mené à l'école autour de
l'escrimé et du golfe merci à tous les
deux firmes